en este vídeo les voy a decir por qué si
la empresa de zapatos ven en la empresa
zapatos jason son fundamentalmente el
mismo negocio eso sí tienen diferencias
en su estructura capital cuál de las dos
es una mejor empresa o un cual
convendría invertir mayor cantidad de
dinero para esto bien se cuenta que sus
ingresos y su ganancia bruta es
exactamente la misma lo que genera la
misma economía en la parte operacional
en lo que van a diferir es la estructura
de su capital en particular el negocio
de jason tiene un gasto financiero de 10
mil pesos mientras que el negocio de ven
no lo tiene ahora bien si nos fijamos y
observamos el activo que tienen ambas
empresas en la hoja de balance vamos a
ver que ambas empresas tienen 20 mil
pesos en efectivo
estos son los 20 mil pesos en efectivo
de ambas empresas y después tienen 100
mil pesos invertidos en inventario es
todo esto de aquí lo puse con color
morado y lo puse proporcional
estos son los 100 mil pesos y estos son
100 mil pesos y después tenemos 20 mil
pesos invertidos en maquinaria o en su
dado caso aquí con este color
en equipo entonces son estos 20 mil
pesos aquí y estos 20 mil pesos de acá
ahora habrá que fijarnos qué es lo que
va a pasar con el pasivo si se dan
cuenta estamos suponiendo que tienen
establecimientos muy parecidos y todo
parece ser casi idéntico pero su
estructura capital es distinta y es ahí
donde va a cambiar todo vamos a ver qué
es lo que pasa primero con los pasivos
entonces vamos a escribir de ambos lados
pasivo tanto en la empresa deben en la
empresa de zapatos de sus pasivos vamos
a escribirlo bien aquí están sus
respectivos pasivos y en la empresa de
jason también pasivos muy bien lo
primero que quiero que veamos es que
ambos tienen deudas a pagar de 5 mil
pesos justo esto es lo que nos está
enseñando en la hoja de balance
supongamos no sé que le deben a sus
trabajadores un cierto sueldo que deben
alguna renta qué sé yo pero lo que sí sé
es que hasta aquí seguimos otra vez
igual por lo tanto vamos a dibujarlo de
una manera proporcional y vamos a
mantener la cantidad de pasivos
proporcional a lo que ya habíamos
dibujado también vamos a agregar esta
deuda a la tienda de zapatos de jason
entonces vamos a dibujarlo aquí estos
son como cinco mil pesos proporcionales
o tal vez un poquito menos no sé en
general son 5000 pesos pero aquí es
donde cambia la empresa de jason a con
base en la empresa deben porque si se
dan cuenta en la hoja de balance de la
empresa de jason la empresa de zapatos
de jason tiene una deuda de 100 mil
pesos aparte de esa deuda a pagar rápido
de 5 mil pesos es decir la cantidad que
tienen de pasivo en la empresa de
zapatos de jason es mucho mayor a la
cantidad de pasivo que tiene la empresa
de zapatos deben que solamente es de 5
mil pesos ahora bien la forma de pensar
en cómo pagar estas deudas está pensado
en la estructura del capital si se paga
con pagos diferidos o se paga
directamente del capital va a depender
según la administración de cada una de
las empresas espero que hasta aquí vaya
todo en orden con todo lo que tiene que
ver con activos y compasivos porque
recuerden que nuestro capital es el
activo menos el pasivo por lo tanto en
el caso de la empresa de zapatos de
jason sean 240 mil pesos de activo le
vamos a quitar 5 mil más 100 mil pesos
nos va a quedar 35 mil pesos solamente
de capital mientra
en el caso de empresa de zapatos deben
es mucho mayor si a los mismos 140 mil
pesos de activo le quitamos solamente
los 5 pesos de deudas a pagar que
tenemos en la compañía deben no nos van
a quedar 135 mil pesos de capital 135
mil pesos de capital y es justo aquí
donde radica la diferencia entre una
empresa y la otra no solamente del
capital porque si nosotros nos fijamos
en sus acciones como ambas empresas
tienen el mismo número de acciones
entonces hay que dividir la cantidad de
capital entre la cantidad total de las
acciones de la empresa y así saber el
valor de cada una de las acciones por
ejemplo en el caso de la compañía de
orán es 135 mil entre 10.000 mientras
que la compañía de 10 unos 35 mil entre
10.000